[موسيقى]
مساء الخير
الانتخابات التركيه ونتائجها تستحق عده
حلقات لان ما يجري في تركيا هذا البلد
الكبير المهم يؤثر على كل دول العالم وان
شاء الله نخصصه حلقاتا للشان التركي تباعا
ولكن بعد ان تنتهي الانتخابات ونعرف من هو
الرئيس التركي بعد يوم 28 مايو المقبل في
هذه الحلقه التي اسجلها يوم 21 مايو اي
قبل جوله الاعاده بعده ايام وحاول فقط ان
اضع حضراتكم في اجواء الانتخابات التركيه
ونحاول الاجابه على سؤال واحد فقط من هو
الاقرب للفوز بالرئاسه التركيه الرئيس
الحالي اردوغان ام منافسه كمال كالشيدار
اغلوم محاوله الاجابه على هذا السؤال
تقتضي ان نعرف اولا ماذا حدث في جوله
الانتخابات الاولى التي جرت يوم 14 مايو
المقبل
اذكركم ان انتخابات عامه جرت انتخابات
عامه على المستوى البرلماني والرئاسي يوم
14 مايو الماضي
قبل 14 مايو الماضي بعده ايام بل بعده
اسابيع
ذهبت معظم استطلاعات الراي ومعظم تقديرات
خبراء الشان التركي في العالم الى
الاعتقاد بان المعارضه هي الاقرب لحسم هذه
الانتخابات في الجوله الاولى على المستوى
البرلماني وعلى المستوى الرئاسي كيف
تتوقعوا ذلك استطلاعات الراي كانت هذه
اراء المواطنين اما بالنسبه لتقديرات
خبراء الشان التركي فكانت قناعتهم انه
المعارضه سوف تفوز بسبب الاداء المتواضع
لاداره الاقتصاد التركي من جانب حكومه
اردوغان وحزبه
اثنين السخط الشعبي من جانب شرائح تركيا
على اداء الحكومه فيما يتعلق بزلزال سته
فبراير 2023 والذي راح تحيته عشرات الالاف
من الاتراك
وتهم فساد احاطت بحكومه اردوغان ومقربين
منهم السبب الثالث هو رغبه
كثير من الاتراك خصوصا بين الشباب في
التغيير اردوغان حكم اردوغان وحزبه يعني
حكموا تركيا العشرين عاما وحان وقت
التغيير
لكن اردوغان والائتلاف الذي يقوده هذا
السياسي المتمرس فاجا الجميع يوم 14 مايو
واستطاع ائتلافه ان يحقق الاغلبيه في
الانتخابات البرلمانيه
وامنوا لانفسهم 321 مقعد من اجمالي عدد
المقاعد في البرلمان التركي البالغ عددها
600 فيما ان المعارضه المكونه من سته
احزاب لم تستطع الا
الحصول على المعارضه الرئيسيه يعني
بقياده كمال كلشيدال اوغلو لم تستطع
الحصول الا على بيتين وثلاثه عشر مقعد فقط
على المستوى الرئاسي فشل اردوغان في حسم
الانتخابات من الجوله الاولى لاول مره في
عشرين عاما اي لاول مره منذ ان ظهر
اردوغان على الساحه السياسيه التركيه
كلاعب رئيسي وحصل على 49 واربعه من عشره
فقط من اصوات اللاخرين هذه النتيجه اقل
طبعا من اخر انتخاب من نتيجه اخر انتخابات
رئاسيه خاضها اردوغان في 2018 حينها حصل
على 52.6
حاسما الانتخابات الرئاسيه من الجوله
الاولى كما اعتاد ان يفعل منذ ان جاء الى
الحياه السياسيه في 2002 و2003
لكن هذه النتيجه
الاقل نسبيا من النتائج التي اعتاد
اردوغان ان يحققها ظلت افضل مما حققه كمال
كلشيدار اوغلو الذي لم يحصل الا على 44
وتسعه من عشره في المئه تقريبا يعني اقل
من 45% من اصوات الناخبين
ومنذ ظهور هذه النتائج في اليوم التالي
يعني في يوم 15 مايو والسؤال المطروح كيف
حقق اردوغان هذه المفاجاه
الاجابات كثيره وتتوقف على من يجيب
المعارضه التي تتهم اردوغان مثلا
بالتلاعب او يعني
السيطره على المشهد الانتخابي او اذا كنت
انت من حزب العداله والتنميه ومن انصار
اردوغان او اذا كنت محايدا اذا كنت محايدا
تستطيع ان ترى هذه الانتخابات انتخابات
صحيحه
سليمه مئه في المئه وان لم تكن نزيهه مئه
في المئه والفرق بين صحيحه ونزيهه قصه
يطول شرحها يعني صحيحه يعني لا تستطيع ان
تشكك فيه شرعياتها نزيهه مئه في المئه لا
لانه عاده الدول اللي مثل تركيا ودول
الشرق الاوسط وتركيا افضل بكثير جدا من
الدول العربيه على المستوى الديمقراطي
لكنها تظل اقل نزاهه من طبعا الديمقراطيات
المستقره في الغرب في المانيا في فرنسا في
بريطانيا في شمال اوروبا الانتخابات صحيحه
لكن تشوبها تجاوزات تتلخص في قدره الحزب
الحاكم على الجيش كل قدرات الدوله لخدمته
لكن تظل انتخابات صحيحه اذا كنت محايدا
سوف ترى ان السبب الرئيسي في فوزه في
الانتخابات في الجوله الاولى يرجع في
تقديري الى نجاح استراتيجيته في اداره
الحمله الانتخابيه استطاع هذا الساحر
الحاوي المتمرس الداهيه ان يجرد الانتخاب
المعارضه من اهم اسلحتها وايه اهم سلاح في
يد المعارضه الاوضاع الاقتصاديه المترديه
في تركيا
اردوغان قفز على هذه الاتهامات وعلى هذه
الحقيقه المره واستطاع ان يقنع عددا كافيا
من الناخبين الاتراك بان هذه الانتخابات
لا تتعلق بالاقتصاد التركي السيء يقر بان
الاقتصاد سيء ولكنه يتعهد بقدرته على
اعادته للانتعاش مره اخرى لكن الاهم من
الملف الاقتصادي انه اقنع هؤلاء الناخبين
ان المساله ليست مساله اقتصاد ولكنها
مساله تتعلق بمستقبل تركيا بامن تركيا
بهويه تركيا برغبه قوه خارجيه بين قوسين
الغرب تحديدا والولايات المتحده على وجه
الخصوص
الراغبه في وقف طموحات ومساعد تركيا لتكون
قوه كبرى تحت قيادته اذا نجح يعني
ركز على مساله الهويه اكثر بكثير من
القضايا الاقتصاديه التي ركزت عليها
المعارضه
ركز على الهويه التركيه باعتبارها دوله
مسلمه محافظه في مواجهه معارضه اتهمها
بتبني قيم غربيه غريبه على الشعب التركي
المسلم اتهم المعارضه مثلا بانهم يدافعون
عن المثليين والمتحولين جنسيا وهذه مساله
تثير حفيظه قطاع كبير من المسلمين
المحافظين في تركيا اللي هم بيمثلوا
القاعده الانتخابيه الرئيسيه لاردوغان
وحزبه ذات التوجه الاسلامي المحافظ
لمح بعض من انصار
اردوغان وليس اردوغان نفسه الى هويه كمال
كالشيدار اوغلو باعتباره علويا والعلويين
طبعا اقليه دينيه تم التمييزه ضدها لسنوات
طويله في تركيا
اردوغان نفسه قال ذات مره ان هؤلاء
العلويين اخترعوا دينا جديدا
وحاول كمال كلشيدار اوغلو نزع هذه الورقه
من حزب العداله والتنميه وانصار اردوغان
بالحديث صراحه على هويته الدينيه من خلال
واحد من فيديوهات اليوتيوب التي كان يخاطب
بها ناخبيه هل كان تاثير هذه المصارحه
ايجابي ام سلبي مساله تحتاج الى تحليل لكن
بالنظر الى انه نتائج الانتخابات لكم لم
تكن عظيما نستطيع ان نقول ان تاثير هذا
الفيديو الذي طرح قضيه مسكوتا عنها وغير
مطروحه على المستوى الرسمي لم يكن فكره
عظيمه على الارجح
اردوغان ايضا استخدم فكره الامن لجذب
الناخبين اقصد فكره الامن ليه بدلا من
الحديث عن الاقتصاد وقدم نفسه على انهم
الرجل القوي الذي يحمي تركيا من الارهاب
اي ارهاب اردوغان يقصد نوع اساسي من
الارهاب وهو ارهاب الجماعات الكرديه
المسلحه الراغبه في الانفصال او للحصول
على وضع مختلف
داخل تركيا بقياده حزب العمال الجورتستاني
الذي هو في صراع مع تركيا منذ اكثر من
اربعه عقود
وفي مره من المرات في احد الجولات
الانتخابيه اردوغان عرض مقطع فيديو يظهر
قيادي عسكري لحزب العمال الكردستاني يدعم
في هذا القيادي كمال كلشيدار اوغلو وعلق
اردوغان لن نسمح لكمال الجدار اوغل الذي
يسير مع المنظمات الارهابيه بتقسيم هذا
الوطن المعارضه كمال الشيدر اوغلو قالت ان
المقطع برمته مفبرك واتهمت روسيا بانها
وراء هذه المقاطع المفبركه والمعارضه
اتهمت روسيا باتهامات كثيره خلاصتها انها
تتدخل في هذه الانتخابات لصالح حليفها
اردوغان وهذه قصه يطول شرحها تغني
ركز كثيرا على الناشونال برايد على العزه
الوطنيه على المشاعر القوميه على رغبه
الاتراك في ان يكونوا دوله عظيمه ولذلك
اختار شعاره القرن التركي المئه سنه
القادمه للاترا اي انه فضل ان يتحدث عن
مستقبل مشرق بدلا من ان ينكرر الحديث عن
واقع الاقتصاد التركي المجزوء الماذون
الان الذي ركزت المعارضه عليه في المقابل
صور المعارضه بانها ليست الا ادوات في يد
الغرب لا تستطيع ابدا ان تحقق استقلال
وقوه تركيا كما يحلم هو
عزز هذه الاستراتيجيه بالتركيز على
انجازاته انجازاته تحدث فيها عن تحديدا
المشروعات الكبرى المشروعات الكبرى ديت
متعدده طبعا على مدار سنوات مختلفه لكنه
ركز على المشروعات الكبيره اللي كان حريص
على افتتاحها واحد تلو الاخر في الايام
والاسابيع القليله قبل دخول الانتخابات
وخصوصا المشروعات التي تتعلق بالصناعات
العسكريه
الصناعات العسكريه الصناعات العسكريه زي
ايه يعني زي مثلا المقاتله قانت تركيا
مقاتله مميزه بتدخل بتستعد يعني
دخول الخدمه او لتطويرها خلال السنوات
القليله المقبله بتركيز على اول حامله
طائرات تركيه حامله الطائرات اللي اسمها
اناضول على ما اذكر
بالحديث كثيرا عن اول سياره كهربائيه
تركيه وقال في 26
الماضي نسعى جاهدين لتحويل تركيا الى مركز
عالمي لانتاج تقنيات انظمه الشحن
والبطاريات وده طبعا
مستقبل صناعه السيارات في العالم
اردوغان مش بس اعتمد على ذلك ولكنه كان
حريص على اثاره الخوف الخوف من ايه مش
الخوف بس من ان المعارضه دي تكون ادوات
ضيعه في يدي من اطلق عليهم الارهابيين ولا
الخوف من انهم يكونوا ادوات في يد الغرب
الذي يريد ان يجعل من تركيا دوله ضعيفه
تابعه للولايات المتحده ولكن الخوف ايضا
من كون المعارضه قليله الكفاءه غير قادره
على اداره ملفات كبيره في دوله بحجم تركيا
هذه المعارضه مكونه من سته احزاب جاءوا من
كل حد وصوب لا يجمعهم الا العداء لاردوغان
ومعظمهم ان لم يكن كلهم لم يجربوا
كمسؤولين قادرين على اداره هذه الملفات
التي اعتاد اردوغان كما يقول عن نفسه
ادارتها بكفاءه وجداره يعني
وطبعا استفاد اردوغان كثيرا طوال هذه
الانتخابات من كونه رئيس الدوله المهيمن
على خزائنها فاستطاع مثلا انه يجير هذه
الامكانيات لصالحه يعني اعطى مثلا زياده
45%
زياده في رواتب الموظفين قبل الانتخابات
باربعه او خمسه ايام
رفع الدعم رفع الدعم يعني زاد نسبه الدعم
على المحروقات قبل الانتخابات ايضا بايام
وهكذا
طبعا استفاد كثيرا من الاعلام يعني
الاعلام اللي سيطر عليه حزب العداله
والتنميه والائتلاف
الداعم لاردوغان منذ سنوات طويله افرد
تغطيه ايجابيه ويعني كبيره جدا لتحركات
اردوغان فيما انه كمال كلش دار اوغلو كان
محروما من تغطيه مماثله واضطر في نهايه
المطاف ان يلجا الى منصه اليوتيوب
ليقدم فيديوهاته من خلال مائره مطبخه كما
يعني اعتاد ان يفعل وهو ما سخر منه
اردوغان في واحد من خطاباته يبقى سؤالين
هل هذه الاستراتيجيه تضمن اردوغان الفوز
في الجوله الثانيه
الاجابه المختصره جدا ووفقا للمعطيات
الحاليه ما لم تحدث مفاجات او تطورات لا
نعلم بها فان اردوغان والاوفر حظا للفوز
في الانتخابات التركيه يوم 28 مايو بعد ان
اضاعت المعارضه بقياده كمال كلشيدار اوغلو
فرصها في الفوز في الجوله الاولى على
المستوى الرئاسي وعلى المستوى البرلماني
ولكن مره اخرى كل الاحتمالات وارده
السؤال الثاني والاهم ما الفرق في
السياسات اذا جاء كمال كالشيدار اوغلو او
اذا استمر اردوغان في السلطه من الافضل
هذا السؤال الاجابه عليه تتوقف على من
يطرحه اذا كنا نتحدث مثلا على روسيا
فالافضل لها بلا ريب هو اردوغان دعمته
تراهن عليه عقدت معه اتفاقات طبعا كثير
منها سري لكن يعني ارهاصاتها واضحه في
العالم اردوغان دافعه ويدافع عن علاقات
قويه جدا مع الروس فيما انه كمال كلشيدار
اوغلو يهاجم روسيا يتهمها بدعم غير نزيه
لاردوغان يتهموها بالتدخل في الانتخابات
التركيه لصالح اردوغان وبالتالي بلا ريب
الروس يفضلون ان يكون اردوغان على راس
السلطه في تركيا في السنوات المقبله
بالنسبه للغرب واضح الاجابه الغرب دي كدول
كثيره لكن بصفه عامه الولايات المتحده دول
الاتحاد الاوروبي قيادات حلف الناتو تفضل
مرشحا اخر غير اردوغان يعني مرشح المعارضه
خصوصا بان كمال كالشيدار اوغلو تعهد بان
يخفف التوتر الموجود مع الغرب بان يخفف
التوتر الموجود مع دول حلف شمال الاطلسي
تعهد برفع العوائق امام انضمام السويد
التي اعاق اردوغان انضمامها لانه اتهمها
بايواء عناصر حزب العمال الكردستاني فضلا
عن وعود اخرى بنظام برلماني لا تتركز فيه
السلطات في يد الرئيس كما هو حادث الان في
ظل حكم اردوغان
بالنسبه لدول الشرق الاوسط دول الشرق
الاوسط كثيره ومتعدده موقف ايران هيختلف
عن موقف المغرب هيختلف عن موقف الجزائر عن
موقف مصر عن دول الخليج كل دوله لها
توجهتها لكن بصفه عامه باستثناء دول قليله
جدا تتمتع بعلاقات متميزه جدا مع اردوغان
مثل قطر
كثير من دول المنطقه تفضل ان يكون هناك
تغيير في القياده التركيه صحيح انه
اردوغان وده من بين الاسباب التي
يعني عززت فرسه في الفوز في الجوله الاولى
سحب احد اهم اوراق المعارضه
بالمزايده عليها وتبني نفس مطالبها ولكن
بدا في تنفيذها باعتباره في موقع السلطه
يعني المعارضه مثلا قالت لازم نعيد
العلاقات مع سوريا هو قطع عليها الطريق
وبدا في مفاوضات مع الرئيس بشار الاسد
وساعده الروس في ذلك اتهموه مثلا بتوطير
العلاقه مع اسرائيل بادر باعاده العلاقات
مع اسرائيل وزير خارجيته اسرائيل وزار
رئيس اسرائيل
انقره بادر الى تحسين العلاقات مع دول
الخليج يجري مفاوضات جاده لاعاده العلاقات
مع مصر وبالتالي بالرغم من تغيير الكثير
من السياسه التركيه المتشنجه مع كثير من
دول المنطقه لكن تبقى كثير من دول المنطقه
لا تثقوا كثيرا في اردوغان وان كانت مضطرة
للتعامل معه وتفضل لو تعاملت مع رئيس اخر
لا يعكر صفو العلاقات معه او لا تعكر صفو
العلاقات معه سياسات طويله اتبعها اردوغان
ضد هذه الدول
فيما يتعلق بفئات معينه الافضل للكرد
يقينا هو كمال كلشيدار اوغلو
مقارنه بالسياسات المتشنجه اتجاه الجامعات
الكرديه سواء في تركيا او خارج تركيا فيما
يتعلق باللاجئين الافضل لهم
اردوغان كل الرؤساء كل المرشحين للرئاسه
التركيه اردوغان
والمرشحين الثلاثه اللي اصبحوا الان مرشح
واحد
كلهم تحدثوا بشكل سلبي ضد اللاجئين
وتعهدوا
بمعالجه هذه المشكله اي بمحاوله اعاده
اكبر عدد ممكن من اللاجئين فضلا عن عدم
استقبال مزيدا من اللاجئين لكن
اردوغان هو الاكثر تعاطفا مع هؤلاء
اللاجئين هو الاقل حماسا لاعاده اعداد
كبيره بشكل قصري منهم الى سوريا او
افغانستان او غيرها من الدول نعم سوف يسعى
كما قال الى تشجيع اكبر عدد منهم الى
العوده سوف يسعى للتاكد من عدم تدفق مزيد
من اللاجئين الى بلاده لكنه سوف يكون اقل
تشددا تجاههم من كمال كلشيدار اوغلو
الحريص جدا على
التخلص منهم في اسرع وقت ممكن بالنسبه
للجماعات الدينيه اخواني المسلمين
والتيارات الاسلاميه الاخرى اللي مرتبطه
مصالحها بتركيا في ظل رئاسه اردوغان وحزبه
العداله والتنميه فالافضل لها بكل يعني
وضوح الرئيس اردوغان الذي حتى وان لم يعد
قادرا على
رعايتهم ودعمهم بنفس القوه
وبنفس الشكل الذي داب عليه في السنوات
المقبله سوف يظل افضل لهم بكثير من كمال
كالشيدار اوغلو الذي لا يرغب ابدا في
تعاون تركيا مع هذه الجامعات ويفضل لو
استطاع
ان يخرجهم من تركيا باسرع وقت ممكن
لكل طرف امنياته هل تتحقق هذه الامنيات ام
لا سؤال سوف يظل مرهونا بمن يفوز في
الانتخابات المقبله وحين تتضح الانتخابات
ونعرف من هو الفائز سوف يكون لنا حديث عن
حجم التغيرات الحقيقيه والفرق بين الوعود
الانتخابيه وما يحدث على ارض الواقع
ونتحدث بشكل اوضع عن ضرورات الامن القومي
التركي التي سوف تفرض مقتضياته على الرئيس
القادم في هذه الظروف المتغيره اذا كان
اردوغان او كمال كالجدار اوغلو اشكركم
والى لقاء